still
look how SA
just work
[Music]
oh
I'm go like this and I get over here
here you don't want to do the sh it
doesn't matter right it doesn't matter
for
me it's still the
same w
o
[Applause]
[Music]
right there's the place to
be where just your body being there is
all that it
takes that's what you're trying to
figure
out you're trying not to uh
go now you're trying to figure out and
his energy is
telling where that
is you have to let him push on
well I have to relax
[Music]
[Applause]
he's going to do what he wants toes what
he does everything he does is perfect
[Music]
if I try to go here and I'm not getting
it maybe I go
here maybe I go here
that excellent k for that
technique and I have never done before
you understand that's the point that's
the point in G was everything is perfect
okay okay so I I've asked to and I've
asked you to not stand
still right we're trying to there
there's some things that um like if you
were in a striking art and he's trying
to hit me you already know how to change
angles you learn it okay but
I we don't we don't do it at the
beginning because there's so much else
to work on
well Gaza is where you don't have to
work on anything right there's no form
to do so you can already start working
on the
angles so I'm not going to be here then
I do my
technique see I move
so let's bring that in
two even though you don't have anything
to do I don't want to see you do
this okay it's too many [\h__\h] turns
it's not
Marshall
okay the idea is T coning is to get ahe
on the spiral because you're going to
knock the hell out of him when he comes
to that Apex that second Apex do you
understand so it's not to sit here one
with the universe one with the universe
no if you if you're doing a t con right
you're right there to knock that crap
out of him it should be that so if
you're doing
s boom should be the
there it's
not it's not here you guys understand
okay then the second thing is his
balance should be
compromised so if I compromise it one
way don't bring back his posture you
understand so I compromis it a little
maybe
boom I just need a little extra
to get that balance to work against okay
don't go damn he didn't go let me change
direction and give him back his b okay
let's you keep doing
[Applause]
if I got herst her one
way I go over
here it's not important to me to get
under the arm unless she lifts
it so why am I pushing her
thigh she's breaking
Center you see Ronin
she's doing that cuz she's nervous so
who cares I don't care there's nothing
wrong with it this is gu boom did it
work yeah it worked right here you
go like this you go around like this
you're like whoa okay
look he's telling you what to do I'm
trying to eat you he's whoa he's strong
strong okay we'll go this
way
okay let let your ego go
go all right stop oh
my this is Unbecoming of a
warrior it's not just for there's a lot
of people if I were to take you right
now you
start that is
unacceptable you're accepting it but
we're labeling it unacceptable okay you
got to get yourself in
gear you got to be strong
mentally physically
emotionally you understand is the
Assumption of the warrior
Arts that you are not
breakable that you will die before
before you
break that is the
Assumption do you understand that that
is the
Assumption you're not going
fast you are directed to go slow you're
only dealing with two different
cues straight grab diagonal
grab you can do anything you
want this
environment is not capable of breaking
anyone but for someone who's already
broke meaning you're just not exposed to
it all the other hours of the day
see you got to grow some repelling
energy to that
Frailty you're not going to overcome it
just because you you are attracted to
being
strong you must be
repulsed by that
fragility that's the
difference you're not sickened by
it you're more sick of me pointing it
out than you are of it
that's where we're
different so you've been given
techniques calm
down
breathe let them push you don't contest
from space for
space they will tell you where to go put
your body where it needs to go to do
nothing but accomplish
everything all of those things will
require less energy from
you so you will not
break from fatigue because this should
not be
fatiguing this is a very gentle
environment but it did his job it
exposed okay do something about it
now tell yourself never again never
effing
again then go do the work so that never
happens again do the
work I saw you might see it eventually
it's a little video going around
about
Edison he sent home from
school with this
letter and he's told by the
teacher you don't read it you give it to
your
mom he gives a letter to his mom the mom
reads it she looks very shooken up and
nervous and he says what what is it
saying
so she reads it to him she holds it in
front of her face she's reading it to
him Mrs Edison your son is a
genius he is too smart for this
school please educate him at
home puts it
away he gets schooled by his parents
video flat you know fast forward he's
the man he finds the
letter takes it out opens it reads it Mr
Edison your son is an
idiot he needs more help than this
school can give
him please educate him at
home then the person person who made the
video points to
this a kind word can change the
destiny do you think that's all his mom
did she probably worked her freaking ass
off
right that's the difference you can't
just say I'm repelled by this Frailty
you got to do the
work no kind words kind words don't mean
[\h__\h] in Warrior traditions we don't care
what you
say we only care what you
do that's
it that's why silence is so
appreciated talking explaining answering
you sound like a person who doesn't
do that's what your fellow Warriors
going to hear when you start
talking because obviously you don't
understand the only thing we care about
what are you going to
do it's not more complicated than
that so first
get the
repulsion now make it never come up
again do the
work is that
clear make it so